so let's talk about your love story a
bit you mentioned in the trailer that
you're moving to Ethiopia for someone
you barely even know what was it about
Binyam that made you say okay I'm gonna
uproot my entire life and move to a new
country you know in a way it's true I
barely even knew him at the same time
when you meet someone and you have that
connection you can feel like you know
someone even if it's only been a matter
of months like for example for us at
that time but the other thing was I
decided that I wanted to try at least
have the experience of being together
because I really wanted to start my own
family and you figured that what MIT
what was it about Binyam that you said
okay I will want to start a family with
him well the funny thing is that I will
say one of the first I think the first
time we ever really spent time together
he just laid it on me he said I want a
serious life I want a wife and I want a
baby and I want you know like a good job
I want all these things and my thought
at that time was oh my god like this is
too much like I just met you and just
calm down but you got what he wanted
when I came I came to appreciate that
especially when I realized that I was
about to have my own family
well you mentioned your recent divorce
do you think that that had any effect on
your current relationship with Binion
yes of course I definitely believe and
see that all the relationships that we
have in our life sort of lead us to to
act a certain way and I definitely feel
like I feel like I'm not talking out of
turn here by saying that you'll
definitely see that effect in the show
but both for me and for Binion but I you
know what I think that it was partially
you know one of the things that did lead
me to wanna travel I mean I've always
wanted to travel the world but one of
the things that led me to
that particular time was because I
really wanted to after being with
someone from a very young age I really
wanted to be with myself to get to know
myself and like it says I wasn't you
know I was not looking for love you I
really was for myself so that's
definitely one of the reasons why I
decided to travel in love came what is
your message for people who might say
that Binyam is a rebound from your
previous relationship yeah I can I can
see how people you know might think that
in a way but I think that the best the
best thing I can say to that is you know
well one thing the first thing I'll say
is I got a baby boy out of it so it
didn't go too bad but the other thing
I'll say that you know in relationships
whether you end up with the person
forever or not you definitely learn
something from them and you you know you
grow as a person and you learn something
about yourself so I don't think that uh
it's a it's a loss either way that's all
what can you tease about your delivery
process how was the experience for you
it was the most emotional experience of
my life I to be honest I before you know
I've never given birth before this is my
first time and I I feel like maybe I I
definitely wasn't prepared I don't know
if anyone is actually prepared you know
they say take classes and do all these
things and read books but it doesn't
prepare you that in my opinion I will
say that one of the most emotional
scenes for this season is definitely
going to be the scene where I'm giving
birth so let's be real here because the
90 day fiancé fans are very opinionated
are you ready for maybe the negativity
you may hear online when people hear
your story or their thoughts have you
mentally prepared yourself for that yeah
I think you know of course you know
nobody wants to hear negative comments
or but I think the the best way that I
prepared
myself is just too you know in life in
general to understand that people always
have an opinion and you know if you take
it to her if you take every opinion to
heart you know you'll be paralyzed
so I on one hand I I definitely you know
I was nervous about that at first but at
the same time you know I think anyone
are taking an interest in my story
whether they come away with a positive
opinion for now well before the season
starts what do you want fans to know
about your relationship with Binion well
I would definitely I definitely think
that anyone who watches us will know
that everything you know in terms of how
we met and our connection was definitely
is definitely real I know that there's
some times you know people get
frustrated if they think that things are
not genuine so definitely gonna say that
it is genuine you know everything that's
so when it comes to the rest of the
season what can you tease first what
will we be in store for it yeah so I am
I feel confident to say that my
storyline is gonna be one of the more
emotional in a way heartbreaking and
ranking way although wasn't expecting
that not you know that you'll have to
see what I mean by okay maybe
heart-wrenching emotional and I think I
think I think people are gonna laugh
quite a few months
[Music]